derek hough has wowed us for 13 seasons
on Dancing with the Stars and he said to
do it again this time with partner
deputy Mota everyone on digging director
with et now et caught up with a pair as
a rehearsal Monday night's premiere for
hours what did you nap I've never I've
never taken as member of ever but for
some reason these past weeks we've
you've been like just really tired today
Derek is tired because it's so in demand
including an upcoming guest starring
role on ABC's Nashville doing the whole
routine in one you know an hour so my
dad I'm not used to that you know
learning a whole bunch of lines it's a
different part your brain so it's kind
of ironic Bethenny is being billed as
the star some outfit ideas if you're
going on a date with that cute boy that
you like she has more than 7 million
YouTube subscribers helping her to get
votes I think the best part is going to
see like what the response is gonna be
on Twitter and Instagram so my viewers
always get really involved in everything
that I do so I think they're gonna have
a lot of fun I'm nervous about that
actually gonna be like Derek different
better boy Turkey better do this yet
Derek arguably has the bigger name and
here's why 5 Mirabal trophies plus an
Emmy for choreography plus he sings and
acts consider this it was Bethany who
flew to Derek in Nashville for their
dance rehearsal not the other way around
he's a man of many trades isn't he he
and Bethany will hit the dance floor
when the new season of Dancing with the
Stars wears Monday September 15th but I
want to know who you guys be rooting for
tweet me at the director using the
hashtag ET now 3t now I'm director
you